yeah College is where all of a sudden
they get the the white nationalist
haircuts yeah what's up with that I
don't know the way I don't get it
why isn't that all the women on the left
have the same haircut as like the the
far-right or whatever I don't know
far-right makes sense I hate using that
term because it doesn't really prop like
you know I don't know whatever their
heads they they pull the hair up and
then shape the side I don't know and
it's like maybe it's because because
it's it's a masculine look they want you
know we've talked about sex versus like
male versus female a couple times you
know how like when you're younger a
female is more has more opportunities
and then it goes down as you go and then
the man it's different so as they get
older they see older men are more are
more privileged in a sense you know more
they get more so it's not surprising to
know that as they get older they're like
well I want a piece of that I'm losing
I'm losing what I had and now I'm
getting older and I'm losing some of
that aspect of youth that I mean not
even yet but you know you can kind of
see how it it would play a part that
they want to be a little bit more
masculine in a sense what makes them so
angry you know well because most parents
probably don't teach them that life
sucks and you have to work hard but life
snowplow parents yes it does if you if
you aren't prepared for it if you think
you're entitled to everything it sucks I
don't think if you if you know you've
got to work for it if you got to get out
into life and actually do work wake up
every day and actually work towards
something then it's not that hard
because it's it's something you're used
to but when you're when your parents are
like oh no you got we got this let me
clear all of the problems away from your
life is amazing sucks then but no know
whether or not you are happy or sad has
nothing to do with your abilities it has
to do with whether whether you're
optimistic or pessimistic okay these
people have become the ultimate
pessimists and while what yeah of course
because they think they grew up thinking
that it was gonna be easy for them no no
it's it's
everything's evil everyone's racist
uh-huh the world is is pure evil America
is and Nazi Empire they have they view
everything through the lens of pure evil
and darkness and so they're extremely
just
angry but that but it doesn't explain
where the anger comes from why are they
so angry it's it's an addiction they're
addicted to that anger they they it's
it's like a like a an avalanche but with
the snowball that's slowly growing or
growing of anger in colleges and
whatever and it's it's running over the
people that are that are getting a while
be angry they want to be angry and
they're like oh I can jump into this in
the snowball that's just getting bigger
and bigger with the people that are
angry also and so they're spreading that
message come be angry with us let's go
be angry together at the system that
that is trying to bring us down it's
like well you don't even want to work
for it you just want to be angry let go
of the anger and do some work that's
that comic where the guys like I'm mad
you know the guys like here's a solution
I don't want a solution I want to be
angry exactly they do want to be a high
note that's what I see you know I was I
was told as when other kids some people
there they like being unhappy definitely
they like it and when I was little I
didn't quite understand yeah seems like
to a28 to a child's mind paradoxical how
could you like not liking something no
no no no you're done it in the
complexities that negative feeling when
they wake up and they wallow in
self-pity yep they it's it's satisfying
to them in some capacity well and you
know it when you come across the first
person that sees that and goes oh let me
let me help you let me let me be there
for you it feels so good no I disagree
how how does that not make sense when
you try engaging with these people who
are screaming they don't respond by
being happy and you're not and you're
not engaging to these people like that
sir no no no I'm talking about that
snowball that snowball that's rolling
down they're the ones that are going to
the people that are victims in their in
their own perception and I have these
interviews and conversations out on the
street when I when I we are not that
person
yes uuuuuu you seriously do not
understand the past ten years of my life
when I would go down to these parks mhm
when I was in Occupy Wall Street and cut
and someone would start ranting about
oppression and stuff and I would be
alike I hear you man I'm so sorry have
ins to you they respond with more anger
more anger okay
straight up I would I was talking to
very high-profile blacklivesmatter
person sure who was doing this big rant
someone tagged me that for some reason
because wasn't something I covered okay
and I responded by saying directly the
guy I hear you man
I'm sorry about those experiences tell
me I could help tell me what's going on
his response was to condemn me and just
go angrier times 10 I have been on the
ground where I've interviewed people
where they're like really really angry
and I'm like would you like to tell me
like what's going on no no no because
you're part of the problem screaming and
I'm like I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I
no idea no don't tell me you're sorry
you're not sorry
they get angry or angrier okay that
doesn't prove theirs that doesn't prove
me wrong that's what that's you
personally you and when I'm talking
about as a whole I'm talking about the
average they do not feel satisfaction
when you when you calmly talk to them
and be nice to them they'll feel
satisfaction when you cry and cower in
fear and say please don't take my job
from me then they're satisfied you
aren't a victim you you don't walk
around as a victim the it takes a victim
to go oh I'm a victim too I understand
that's not where you come you dude
you're confident I'm sorry you cannot
hide your confidence ever no matter what
same as me I can't hide acting about a
confident person hold on no no you're
you're a confident person you walk up to
that person you say man I feel you they
see that confidence they don't see you
as a victim and they go you know what
that's a lie I don't believe it at all
that's the point the point exactly what
my point is yes thank you that when
these people are screaming and then you
finally come up to them and give them
you know what they're looking for well
oh I didn't I didn't say necessarily you
I wasn't saying it like that you're
talking about this this behavior of
trying to accommodate accomodate them or
empathize does not result in what you're
saying it results in yeah because it
takes that it's the victims it's the
ones that group together they're the
ones that are like I feel you because
I'm a victim for sure I'm totally a
victim that's nine monarchy you yeah
this is not what happens the only way to
actively function in the circle with
these people not screaming is to say
literally nothing or to cry you can't
start this conversation by saying I
don't understand how this happens and
then finish it by going that's wrong
that's not the way it is I'm sorry
no but I'm right okay I've been on the
Gregory to disagree I've covered this
for over a decade okay you're you you're
sitting here telling me
I'm not telling you anything I'm just
telling you I'm telling you what I'm
what my view of what this is you said I
don't understand this I said this is
what I think it is right okay so
whatever you so so right now you're
being the anti-vaxxer okay I've got
experience on the ground
I was embedded with these groups for
years sure and I'll tell you exactly
what happens why it happens what they've
said to me explain these things and
everything I've seen over the past nine
years the undeniable man and I'm not
even talking about myself I'm talking
about in general when you're at a
protest and you see a woman walk up to
another woman who's screaming and she's
like are you okay and the one goes get
that half away from me you effing and
screams in her face inka when you see
two women who are fighting each other in
a park when antipholus around these
people is saying and doing nothing when
they start screaming and ranting and
they're full of rage people just stand
there and nod and that's it there's
nothing you can say to them go don't
want a solution they want to be angry
but this is this is in occupy you you
want you we're talking about colleges
right after high school
they get indoctrinated in in the college
situation right that's what we're
discussing this is where I was at this
is what I'm talking about so this is
what I think is going on so you were
saying that you went to colleges you've
seen that in colleges where there all
this is happening like when Nick
Christakis was talking to the kids on no
no no I'm talking about you personally
yes and I've been to Berkeley and I've
been to Syracuse and a bunch of other
universities but all the stuff was going
down and I've witnessed this firsthand
and experienced it when I tried doing
similar things okay and there's a really
good example in Nick Christakis the
professor who was accused of being a
bigot because he said something about
Halloween costumes and they surrounded
him and no matter what he said to them
even when he said I'm so sorry I agree
they said shut up
you don't speak and they yelled at him
no matter what he would do and that's
that was a very famous viral moment and
there are many more with professors like
him where you cannot say anything to
these people at all okay and they tell
you that or though or or the guy at
Evergreen when he's talking waving his
hands and they tell you to stop waving
your hands it's racist and then he does
and they all laugh at him but these are
the people that are already in the
Circle they're already indoctrinated
they're the ones that are already
speaking out that are already angry
they're the ones that are already in
these groups
that's who you're referring to right now
it's like a group of kids but how does
it happen how do they how does it how
did they catch the new people by the
people that are just standing on the
side just shaking their head yes and
then they suddenly snap and turn into it
well that's the question I'm asking what
makes them so and that's what I was
referring to what were you saying that
makes them angry well no no I was I was
saying what brings them into it yep what
brings them what makes them angry is
they're there everything pisses them off
everything they thrive in that anger so
because oh what Bill de Blasio's
daughter okay
like you you've referenced her before I
mean I've only in the fact that she went
into college looking one way and and
exited college looking a crazy like a
crazy eyes I don't know anything about
her I don't I'm you know who am I to say
anything about her because that's the
only thing I know about her is that she
looked completely different after high
school so and that she's now an activist
as York it's a meme yeah you know they
say college not even once sees a meme
yeah and they show like people before
college and after college what happens
to where normal people and I know people
like this who all of a sudden can't stop
and have a conversation because they're
dialed to 11:00 non-stop no matter what
they do no matter what you say
everything's at 11:00 have you have you
heard the elephant line versus the
writer mind no I just watched this
earlier a really good little back and
forth interview with Carlin and it was
great and basically what it means is is
the elephant mine is your emotional side
and the writer mind is basically being
controlled by the elephant until you
finally rein it in and you you gain
control of your more rational side the
more logical side of the human brain and
it seems to me that these people are
it's it's basically like the reins of
the the elephant per se has been they've
lost could they broke they have the
reins in their hands they're holding it
really tight but it broke an elephant is
just running a rampant there's and
there's no stopping it it's like a
stampede that's what I see that's
happening that that anger is is run
unchecked for so long backing off or
bouncing off rather other people that
are equally angry making
more anger and that anger just is
getting perpetuated into this like hot
mess and that's what we're seeing you
know it's like it's so easy to want to
be lazy to blame others for your
problems people want to do that
especially when we're growing up without
parents you know where we want to be a
part of something so you get to college
you're finally out of the home which
might not have even a bit good a good
situation
boom they they hit you know this crowd
of people that I mean you're pissed off
now you're angry like I have to go do
work I have to like get up and actually
do stuff like whatever I mean not
everybody some people just drink their
whole college careers but you know
others just get angry so I think it's
specifically no parents it's yeah maybe
maybe this I mean that the statistics
don't lie it's absolutely if you have no
parents or a one parent home like I've
looked into this now and it's you're
absolutely right I mean like weak
parents true and so if it's parents that
aren't even there that I mean what's the
difference you know if you're not
raising your kids if you if you hand
them an iPad that's not raising your
kids that's them learning and and doing
the algorithm till they get you know
dancing Hitler right yeah it's like
crazy it's it's like somebody flicked a
switch in their brains that can't be
turned off yep and they're just wads of
anger and rage mm-hmm you ever seen the
video it's called this video will make
you angry by CGP grey no I haven't seen
it he basically talks about how internet
communities buried hatred and can it
become it you know it's funny is because
he basically predicted all this was
gonna happen and the culture war for
instance and he talks about how groups
don't actually argue with against each
other they argue amongst themselves
about the other group okay and they keep
exaggerating the claims until they've
become so enraged that they're just wads
of anger and that you know they talk
about how video and you talk about this
video social media stuff how it plays
into this mm-hmm so memes for instance
circulate among groups about the other
group and they never actually interact
so I don't know as an interesting idea
but but the reason I was bring this up
is because I remember that video of the
white woman yelling at the black cop
yeah and the guy approaches her and he
was like you know he's a black cop right
or was a little woman right and and
she's and the guy says like what makes
think this is okay and the woman's eyes
man fervent she like how did well you
can always tell too because they don't
start with a with a tone of voice like
this it always is up here it's 11
always always it's like they're on Mac
reaching like you know you can see the
heart is pumping the adrenaline is
flowing they wanted that oh you you
turned on me I can I'm gonna open the
floodgates of anger on you and it's like
everyone who sees that who's a rational
human being it's like whoa like you need
to calm down we need to figure out how
to ever have conversation I mean I think
there are very there are ways to try and
defuse people one of the challenges
going back to the conversation about the
insidious nature of the far left is that
they actively try to stop any attempt by
a person to break someone from the cult
you know you're in the cult they act as
like defense mechanisms screeching with
rage to shut down any conversation and
that but they literally do this like an
example would be if you walk up to one
of these people and you actually start
having a conversation they would run up
to you and get in the way and start
telling you to shut up and then start
chanting you know you can see it right
there was a video with Jack the sobic
conservative talking to a black man in
DC okay and they immediately rush up and
try and stop him from doing it and he I
think it was Jack was it Jack was tech
yeah he's like sure he's like I'm trying
to have a conversation with with my
friends here and they're like screaming
at him shut up shut up because they
don't want people to actually hear yeah
they don't want people to come together
they want to maintain that anger and
rage within you well I certainly see
that right now it's like the it feels
like the left / Democrats that they're
they're trying to slam home this
division between everyone and it's like
I won't have it like I got these people
that are and you know it's great I'm
seeing people stand up there's that
they're starting to look out for each
other you know it's like no you're not
gonna talk to to this person like that
like you're the one who's wrong you know
it's like even on my facebook this this
infamous Facebook tweet teen or you know
whatever it is they post yeah you know
and it's like there's people that I that
I've known my whole life that are now
writing on this
calling this guy out you know for for
being wrong being how in explaining
calmly and I'm like these are the
rational people he was an emotional
person he was he was not thinking
coherently he was screeching at me he
was turned it up to eleven there are
people there are people on the right
overturned up to eleven like you know
III go what's the ratio of people on the
ladders way more than the right absolute
percent otherwise I wouldn't be saying
things I do for most part but it really
does bummed me out like I posted I
parlayed about this that the right
terminology I'm Carl a parlor I parlayed
all the crabs ins Dean's are there and
they're lining thing about them what's
their just like who are these keep
hearing her name a super anti-trump okay
really annoying there you there were you
bigoted no there anti-trump Oh super
anti calm well why did it get booted off
Twitter because they were they were
accused of running multiple accounts
okay and they were like they were
everywhere a free replying to everybody
so they joined parlor and I'm like
excellent excellent yeah bring on bring
on more anti Trump people because if
what we end up with is a Twitter and a
parlor that have their various biases
and in terms of banning speech you'll
have two different spaces where
different conversations happen true
better than just Twitter right agree but
I look at the comments on this guy's
post and there's a bunch of conservative
people's cussing him out and telling
them to f off and just really nasty
things you know and I'm like why yeah
why would you do that you know but but I
will say you look at this is this is a
common trope among the far left it's
called a right-wing love bomb they they
understand and they hate it and they
refuse to understand why it works
they'll say like a regular person will
get all of this love from the right
saying you're so great you're so smart
you know that's that's really great
thanks for having a conversation and it
convinces them to become right-wing and
I'm like yeah well duh right what do you
think if I walk into what if I if I'm if
I'm if I'm in the middle street I look
to my right as a bar with a bunch of
manga people with Trump hats waving
flags and they're hooting and hollering
I looked at my life it's a bunch of ante
for people wearing you know masks with
crowbars and then I walk over the left
wing side and they go who the F are you
bigoted what are you talking about no
I'm in charge when screaming I'm gonna
be like Jesus then I walk across street
and they're like yo but
come have a beer over over with us yeah
and then I'll go well I mean I'm not
really a trumpet hey no problem man
coming in I'll get you a beer we'll have
a conversation and that's hypothetical
right I mean technically it's actually
well look let me let me tell you I am I
am right there
right now I'm standing I'm standing on
that Street I'm seeing these people on
the left that I've known for a long time
screeching at me screaming at me you
know that that marks post that I've said
on Twitter the other day or like last
week it's insane the amount of people
that are freaking out about it on both
sides count screeching at each other but
man all the rational people that are
coming up to me going you know props for
opening your eyes it's like if it's just
that just that alone right there you're
it doesn't matter what I believe in
it's like a simple hey good for you
that's that's really what I'm hearing
good for you
like good on you for furthering yourself
opening your eyes it's not like I'm glad
you're even here which I have gotten but
like the majority is just like good job
like I'm proud of you like good for you
man going go into a like pro-trump group
or forum or or post on Facebook
something where you say something like
I'm not a big fan of Trump mm-hmm and
you know I think we should we need to
get him out of office right okay and the
response you typically get not
completely but typically from
conservatives is you'll get response
where it's like what's your problem with
Trump what has he done
why do you hate him so much yeah the
questioning and then when you say
something like he's racist they'll be
like what has he ever done this racist
for an example I love that hold on I
know a lot of stuff about him out now go
now go to an anti-trump forum in post
I like Trump I think I'm gonna vote for
him oh yeah and you know what's gonna
happen me they're gonna Brant they'll
ban you in two seconds that's true
so so listen I want I'll make sure it's
clear it's like a two-to-one ratio it
exists on the right yeah if you go to
say the Donald dot win and you post
something negative about Trump they're
gonna delete it there right I did go to
and I joined it how did you yeah I was
like I'm gonna see what this is all
about
it's so it's it's it is an echo chamber
of Trump love yeah but but again the
reason I I mentioned is because there's
also our slash politics on reddit mm-hmm
it's supposed to be a neutral political
forum it is just basically incite Ron
so you knew the Donald dot lose if you
go if you go to our slash politics yeah
and post a Pro Donald Trump story erased
well if you go to our slash news
sounds like Facebook gone yeah you go to
so if you go to the dot so this is why
it really it really is a bummer there's
no neutral platform for these kind of
debates yeah you can't post anti Trump
stuff on the Donald OTT win for obvious
reasons it's dedicated to Trump
supporters the Donald Ryan politics
should be neutral you should be able to
talk good and bad about true yeah and
then our / Biden should be Pro Biden an
anti-trump right instead the supposed
neutral platform will ban you for saying
good things about Trump this is the
perfect example of what's going on in
modern politics now typically III just
tell you straight up I have been in tons
of far-left events and hangouts and they
do not tolerate dissent and they've I've
been threatened I go to an event with a
bunch of Trump supporters and I calmly
laid out my discussion about
institutional racism okay and they all
were like mmm I never thought about it
that way I disagree and then we had you
know like I'd like shrimp nip or
something painting chips and we sat
there and they're all like yay Trump and
I was like well here's here's how I see
these issues of social justice and they
were like I don't know I don't agree
with that though and that was it
yeah I disagree and I was like okay Oh
class who's getting the beer classic
conversations well it's because when you
look this is a little civil conversation
to what I was talking about with the far
left you can see this nature their
tactics this is why I'm I'm I'm not
entirely confident on Trump winning they
cheat they don't just cheat in terms of
like we're gonna wring the election they
cheat in terms of discourse yep Chubby's
defeating anyone that's right just
speaks out my video you're of me just
simply going I don't I don't like the
Democrats anymore I'm gonna vote for
Trump band boom got banned 2.4 million
views and they would better delete that
yeah that'll stop running way too fast
Donald Trump comes out and he goes my
fellow Americans we will build a
tremendous Garden of Heroes Frederick
Douglas Harriet Tubman heroes of the
Civil War everybody agrees it'll be
tremendous and then what happens
Donald Trump says he's gonna build
statues of Confederates he thinks the
Confederates are
it's life it's crazy you're lying I'm
making it a latent lying I know it's
insane they will cheat and 100% agree I
I think they're cheating now you're
right thanks for checking out this clip
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you